Gentlemen please direct your attention
to the video board on Saturday former
Penguins forward Adam Johnson tragically
lost his life in a terrible accident on
the ice while playing in the elite ice
hockey league in England Adam was just
29 years
old a big story line coming into
tonight's matchup that being the man who
led the Penguins out on the dice for
warm-ups Adam Johnson a solo lap in the
NHL debut tonight here in the world
famous Broadway just really excited you
know it's been a long time waiting and
this is what I've been working for my
whole life so I'm pumped to be here and
I just hope to uh hope to contribute any
way I can right wing feed for laery
shoots blocker sa made the rebound they
score Adam Johnson puts it home and Adam
Johnson has his first career NHL goal
and it's top shelf baby right where Mama
keeps the peanut butter oh did he Hammer
this one Johnny his first NHL
goal I saw it rolling out there and I
saw on ins side and I was just hoping I
could get all of it happy I got lucky
enough for it to bounce right to me and
it was a good shop I laugh for I've been
hoping to play here for a while and it
was it was a lot of fun to be able to do
it in front of the family and friends
from back home in this home state
[Applause]
for hece swim boys let's keep her going
[Music]
tomorrow Adam was part of the penguin
organization from 2017 to 2020
fulfilling his dream of playing in the
national hockey leag Adam was a great
teammate friend and member of the
Penguins family please join the players
coaches and the entire hockey Community
as we celebrate a life lost too
soon ladies and Gentlemen please stand
and cheer one more time for number 47
Adam
Johnson
[Applause]
[Music]
w